um talk to me about your production
process these days because technology
has uh obviously evolved so much from
when you first started producing so what
is your production setup these days cuz
what what was your OG setup a Rolland
w30 a workstation okay like people that
use the asr1 yeah whatever I had it but
I didn't like the way it was what it was
moving for me so it worked for Timlin
for Kanye West and people like that but
to me it didn't but this station only
have 15 seconds four yeah 15 seconds
compared to a whole bunch of Temple time
so it was treated like a sp1200 the way
I had it going but I was able to play
with it so cuz me being able to play I
wanted to not have just a drum machine
right I wanted this too so the
workstation is what I what I like what I
worked on better even though I got every
machine possible I just stayed with that
you know it was better fast forward to
2024 what's the setup and then I moved
to a um a motif okay because the motif
had mad sampling time and it had 88 keys
to that was heavy like a real piano cuz
again I got I want to play I don't want
to MIDI nothing you know I want to do
this right so and I could also program
too so I'm used to a workstation like
when I was doing Kanye West for the last
since
May soon as I came into this session
with me and him workstation
asr1 no matter what all those years in
90s one machine so if it's not broken
you know say so so again and I watch I
watch Jermaine Dei on his thing when
he's sitting down too MP Roy jerkers
everybody's back on that one machine
yeah cuz it's like nowadays like I'll
see these like younger producers and
they don't even it's just the computer
technology can't give you that it can't
give you that analog you're looking for
or that field or whatever like that that
old machine is so weird that everybody
went back and now the NPC just came out
with the stem thing so now they got the
stem so that's what the the best part of
Technology right now is that stem thing
so now the [__] that we dreamed about
like they talking over it you know n but
you can just take the out out beat out
basine out whatever you can sample
anything now but even if you do have the
technology do you know what to do with
it going to be whack you can be whack
with with this machine I'm trying to
tell DJs I'm like you're a whack DJ it
don't matter they got easier to be a DJ
whack whack people that that know how to
get busy oh it's a [__] a miracle
worker so you've been in with Kanye in
the last few months six months I started
in May 30th doing the first album then
after I went to Italy Tai dollar sign
was there so they had put some thing
called vultures together yeah even
though I still made that project I've
heard a lot of it yeah even though I
still made that project as that wasn't
what I was working on with him so you
were working on uh a yay album Y3 yes
okay M and then you ended up making the
vultures project though no I ended up
going to Italy in the fact that um when
I got there Tai already had sung on one
of my songs already oh fire then I end
up doing another record too when I when
I got to Italy though too so I was in
between so hopefully when this is done
we we get back to Y the Y3 yes um what
cuz I know like Yay has this thing where
he likes to go like certain cities and
like you know My Beautiful Dark Twisted
Fantasy was
Hawaii um the click stuff was like uh I
think it was like in Paris I mean he
moves around but what was like the Italy
sessions like what was that like it's
crazy yeah because we was in Sting's
Place sting yeah fire so his his village
was fantastic you know um and and the
vibe in the room it's crazy how yay like
PA speakers yeah not like not like what
you would think right it's literally
like don't care about the bleeding don't
care about how loud it is he want in the
loud doesn't matter the two Pas and the
and and and the two subs on both of them
and that's it I was in this well I was
in every room yeah we at the hotel we
had it at the warehouse we had it and
and and where we at
South Central I was in Vegas um Ty
invited me out to Vegas when the album
was supposed to come out and we ended up
in y's
suite and same thing it's just two
speakers and he's Tiga was in there YG
was in there uh Little Dirk was in there
all recording while just the room is
still rooming like it was never like
everybody shut up it was we was in the
addition Hotel
crazy that's crazy on the eighth floor
just that's wild and no guess nobody
said [__] did you and Tai were you guys
able to bond a bit I mean obviously you
guys I yeah yeah because cuz his his
brother when I got when I first saw
child he stopped playing all Eric serman
[__] he's because he was saying that my
95 album is what his brother put him on
when I told you he played six records
and knew them all shocked the [__] out
of me you guys got to do the the green
eyes thing the green eyes Duo so but but
he's one of the greatest guys in the
world he's a great songwriter he's he's
a great guy though like a great human
yeah I I I he was mad
nonchalant stayed smoking you know what
I'm saying but again I'm the old head
inside the place right you know because
again I'm N9 years older than yay though
too so even though it's it's me and him
and um and the writers you know whatever
so says you know give out too much but
yay is a person that whatever people say
is not what I experienced he music is
music and that passion that you have as
a producer when you hear something dope
it's like yo same [__] yeah and that's
all it was about about yo being whatever
the the the you can't take nothing from
his ear the vibe the the rhyming the
context all of it that's all I saw I
don't know no other [__] I just know
what we was doing and how he felt about
me right you know you're like yo Eric he
said everybody in here that person who's
doing my wardrobe the person who's
building my building the one who's doing
my president campaign he said these
people over here everybody hear Geniuses
that's why you here hey man you know
that's some real [__] hey take me back
to you guys taking on Rappers Delight
because another terrible uh I have to
admit that I'm I I only knew the death
squad Rappers Delight so even when I
even to this day like I I know the OG
Rappers Delight but even to this day
like when I see like when the OG Rappers
Delight comes on I sing the the death
squad version like what was that like
did you guys initially get any sort of
like blowback for like remaking such a
heralded record listen it wasn't
something to do it was it was a project
that went on MTV yeah yeah and um they
had all the groups pick old records oh
so you guys pick that cuz that was kind
of the theme of the project
did 600 in the morning whatever that
it's called in the beginning okay oh I
remember the the the the there was like
the knuckles with the
ring I the album right in the beginning
everybody did something on there yeah so
when they came and got us this is what
we chose cuz it was three of us three y
not knowing that it was going to shoot a
video MTV number one video like we had
brought the record back like no we we
beat Maxwell by 10,000 records to be
number one album in the country crazy
death squad went number Uno yeah you
know because of what that was but we
didn't do it on purpose but we did get
um blowback from the original people cuz
don't think they still torn with it yeah
so now the death squad then came and now
it took away from them it took a long
time for them to be like yo cuz now when
I see like yo what's up everything is
love but at one time H wasn't [__]
with it at first right because it's
going to stop them from from from moving
around yeah you know we don't know that